yes
[Music]
it's just sitting on my screen Shameless
crew man
imposter again just kidding
damn that's a good one
oh God I lost everyone ah of course you
wouldn't kill me okay
oh God the lights oh God I'm gonna die
where the Corpus Scott
Bobby there he is he's safe yeah Simon
says the most fun game yeah I did it
they left me
yes
oh my God
I called the meeting honestly I was just
curious if someone was dead you can skip
no reason for calling all right Pokey
why did you turn and chase me
immediately
was the other way around you were kind
of whoa no no no no no I ran away from
Felix and then you run out run away from
feeling
anyone's seen saikuno no I've been with
Mr Beastie I saw it sounds like you know
uh weapons get him out of here
that's kind of sucks
I'm gonna hard clear Ray she's 100
innocent where are you going James
yeah I'm pretty sure Jack is there
right
let's chill in the dark
who just passed it
I knew it was rain right a toast did you
report that buddy I did we rolled up
together you're way quicker than me I
was about to press it should we should
we all skip because we got a lot of
tasks done yeah speed run past everybody
everyone's work hard what do you mean
that's a little weird it's really weird
[Applause]
do you have inside information on this
guy I no I don't but why the hell who
says that
you know I'm trusting Bobby on this one
no no no no no no no no no no no yo
saikuno has like the best voice of all
time
I'm sick yeah oh yeah corpse is here now
corpse is great
you know what it is it's like the angel
in the in the demon on each shoulder
it's beautiful I love it the corpse is
the Angel everyone curse this is amazing
Bobby Thomas says doesn't kill very much
it would explain why no one's died okay
uh question at the beginning of the game
corpse you came up from Shields right to
navigation you're asking me what I did
in the beginning of the game it's a
rookie mistake remember anything I'm
telling you that right now uh Dell thing
is Jack during one of the light fixes
you came from the back side of
electrical when Bobby and peels were
fixing the lights why were you on the
back side because that was the first
round I was scared that it might have
been Felix or Pokey so I didn't I didn't
go into lights I went up top and then I
came back yeah
he and Felix were also together all last
round
on me yes yeah no no don't go Jack no
more Jack don't let's not vote anyone
this problem would love nothing more
than my head yeah
yeah
but you should definitely know yeah so
let's just skip yeah let's just wait for
something
yeah we should at least let someone die
first three and a half minutes into the
game where were you this one is shutting
people down there's no there's no dog
piling happening on my watch yeah tell
us it's kind of sister right and why so
keen on boating out checks oh mid Bay
is that one all right watch this biggest
brain play biggest brain play ever okay
let's do it I'm ready
why would I kill PewDiePie because I
don't know trying to blame it on me me
and Felix are following us Jimmy
exactly which is why it's a convenient
story
you can follow me if you want me off you
want to lose
[Laughter]
together PewDiePie and then like I've
reported it right away he was trying to
suffer for it sure he did Mr I fumble on
the report button twice in a row Jack
would kill Felix after he vouched for
Jack yeah that's the thing it doesn't
make sense which is exactly why he would
do it uh it really doesn't make sense
all I'm saying is like
if their jackass a really good innocent
Voice or it was you no I'm terrible at
life I helped PewDiePie win the sub War
why would I kill him
he's Shameless
innocence
he's going all out he looks
oh well he's dead convenient convenient
story bruh
that didn't work all right well I tried
I tried to be a big friend I I thought I
was bigfraid
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh why did that
he probably just got me Shameless watch
the streets does he hit me does he hit
me down
[Music]
it's just sitting on my screen Shameless
wow it can't be all four of us because
we all came in together right
um well this hip must have happened
earlier who do you think it is psychuno
yeah it's most definitely not Jack did I
do that bad of a job that no one thinks
it's Jack
well we're very close on tasks
this is hey I'm just gonna close that
corpse and toast and he's crying yeah
anyway don't come back here come back no
you don't run away from me like this
turn your back on me don't turn your
back on me after all we've been through
I think I made Jimmy cry someone telling
him
all right I'm gonna head out I'll see
y'all
I'm always like Jack nose because it's
always you
that's you just talk differently when
it's you I think you know what it is
wait Jack you can tell the Corey's liar
boys what's the secret wait his voice
it's what he says okay are you
kidding me ah
ah let's go the Among Us God Smiles upon
us today what do I do
oh no they just saw the band they just
saw the band
did something she just saw that I think
she just
it has to be done
wait oh okay
No One's Gonna find him huh wait there's
wait what no one's seeing him
it's going uh
electrical electric I feel like I'm like
playing my own game I don't think I saw
anybody until the very end of that round
there was two people in electrical
wasn't it on admin I checked um
oh you can see that do do the bodies
yeah they do okay
admin literally like a couple seconds
there's two people in electric was that
the person that reported it and then
also the body then I walked in yeah
it was like that for a while but it was
on cams
on cams at all this round nobody I
thought I saw cams on it's probably say
Kuno yeah probably earlier all right I
do I know that Bobby is super Innocent
but thank you
would you deal in absolutes WoW
we'll avenge you say Kuno they'll make a
Netflix documentary on you in like five
years
foreign
I literally walked in the room and was
able to report the body and who was that
that reported it oh it was me it was me
I thought it was uh
that's what they should call you from
now on
that's a good one you got away with
words okay wait
a minute Bobby
I'm an electric
Al
up to the panel here so was it like four
of you in there three PewDiePie well
there was four until someone killed
someone I have a question for you peeds
go ahead why when the lights were off
were you running the opposite direction
of the lights because I don't want to
die that's literally my place right
okay fair enough this is a common thing
yeah
I'm in Med Bay yeah I'm gone past admin
in the middle Jack what are you doing in
Med Bay I ran away from the lights
because I thought someone was going to
kill me did you vent absolutely not I
never vent I'm terrible at it I get
caught every time I vent it makes you
feel better emotionally
[Laughter]
okay Bobby when I was eight my Dad ran
away like I'm going for cigarettes this
kid will be back in five minutes I
promise of course that was good you've
returned all right what are we doing
skipping yeah I guess we have no sauce
of Jack corpse and a sprinkle on toast
because Bobby said so
whoever Bob usually eats us is always
not I'm retracting my suspicions
everyone sees security it's you and Mead
what should we do then oxygen Maybe
sorry dream
what oh the body is outside of admin or
like it's like in admin there's someone
on chems
I didn't see you all winning because
there was a lot of people around
with you I already forgot oh how can I
know I saw a body there was someone on
cams I was like surely they would have
seen who did it he was on cams I did see
him there I was literally calling out as
people were going in and out and I
merely forgot after saying it you didn't
see someone kill on on cams oh no I'm
I'm the best at missing kills on camps
oh my god oh no there's so many clips
and that's why I haven't then why are
you on them I'm not tasks maybe he's
protecting the real killer because he's
the killer that's what I'm thinking too
you did your tasks already yeah that's
very fast wait but if Pewds just came
from admin doesn't it no I didn't come
from Madden
wait what's the rule on seven who did
bottom of two oh two was it I did it I
didn't are we skipping said you didn't
come yeah cause I was done after I went
to comms afterwards
yeah okay
okay sure
Pokey needs to die
where's Pokey it's finer where is that
cafeteria all right
yeah no
okay we can skip skip okay
wait how does this works you guys can
talk I'm just checking I just finished
my tasks
oh yeah
damn they're gonna finish task at this
rate
does Jack says to me because I think he
does
or you can get another killing in
between
yes no
stopped her
all right then
okay this body is on the bottom left
Bobby what were you doing this like like
last 20 seconds card swipe but it was O2
somebody already got it then I was
headed up to weapons which is my last
task and you can follow me
foreign
I went to oxygen with I believe rhyme
style we went there we ran yeah we ran
down to the other O2 for a second to see
who was there I walked out ran through
cafeteria above Med Bay left down
towards like camera area and then this
was called infused where were you I came
from uh admin I'm gonna go with Pewds no
you were the last one
he's playing you oh thank God you guys
if I'm wrong we lose the game here
I could have voted
ah he never said he was going on thank
you corpse wait wait wait it's quite
exciting is voting Ryan I haven't done
it weapons why weren't you doing it I
literally just did it and came
out of it yes I did first of all
you yes I did bro this is exactly what
happened you I was going out of
cafeteria I was headed down
south and I was like why am I doing this
why am I doing this I have to go to
reference and I went to weapons and I
did the little thing that looks
like a pill and I clicked it because
that's all you gotta do you know
Bobby oh did you do 20 asteroids all
Tony I did the little pillow thing where
you click it and it goes like Boop oh so
you don't have the weapons asteroids
damn I don't have weapons asteroids okay
um I think I I would think it's corpse
then me too no the only problem with
corpse is I was alone with them a couple
times yeah less again unless I'm just
set up with this yeah right he voted you
last round last round because to me it
was between like he was the only one
that was us we had to vote someone
because yeah and we were literally alone
the round before
Nick but again I think he was he's
playing it slow he wouldn't set you up
and then toss you out the airlock that
round I thought I did pretty good I
think I lied pretty well considering all
them at this point
ah of course I don't know who it is man
it's not me nice no corpse I'm rooting
for you man let's go
nobody tried to uh sabotage us now right
um okay so I'll tell you why so toast is
banking on you guys getting the size of
me so he's not sabotaging so that you
guys call the button and then vote me up
yeah okay so this is the logic in my
mind so for me I got puked out because I
let the vote now I could be an imposter
throwing out my other imposter to win
the game but then I could have just
voted rhymestyle with corpse and kill an
innocent player and then won the game
off that no you didn't know how many
were voting him though and obviously you
were right because I wanted to clean the
charge on my partner without any reasons
though you do that and like right just
give me anxiety I know it's not Bobby
it's not me I would have called the
sabotage right he hopes you guys call
the button and then vote me here if you
were imposter and corpse was innocent
you would have just vote of course and
you would have won off that so that made
some point with the logic I want to say
Bobby's because I definitely think he
would have sabotaged right yeah Bobby's
100 innocent rhyme style winning on me
against Pew to imposter the only logical
outcome you guys don't know that toast
us all the time yeah that's true
yes calling button and they don't know
right now to win the game I'm about to
make a biggest mistake with the stream
yeah because corpse could have killed me
in the name of Grease
either way you just gotta vote
please tell me to write this again
go Corps well played
huge nice corpse I wish I had my cat
ears we would have been so cute
God damn good luck
[Music]
oh my God
are you
you gotta be kidding me
oh my God holy that's huge
yeah sure
[Music]
oh what they make it so that I can't
vent
oh I'm alive okay okay what happened uh
uh where else I on the outside I don't
know what area it is uh like where
there's a little men oh me yeah like
where they listen clear dream for this
one 100 I
I oh I was afraid of you but but I
trusted you and I lived so uh yeah
that's all I got yeah
bottom left me yeah um I
wall dream we were kind of staring at
each other for a while and then lights
went out and I set it up
like mid he said it yeah
obviously come on
come on
here come on you know who it is I know
it is
we're on the same page come on oh you
guys
being toaster on the same page
apparently but
pokey's bleeding body at camera which is
top left spelled bleeding how do you
know that
yeah she got stabbed a couple times in
the back
um
that was oddly specific did you see it
happen yeah
has anyone seen toes because I I think
it's the only one I've been seen during
that kill I'm pretty confident dream is
innocent
I wanted to to contamination I pass like
and then me and corbus went and fixed
the Meltdown on the right side yes so
what task huge fixed left reactor
what happened where are you what are you
doing oh uh I wanted to do water wheels
wheels yeah water wheels the whole time
is that is that weird Ray I already
voted body the body is at security cam
so that's kind of he's near there I did
water wheels and guess what I also did
the oxygen thing right next to the vet
my gun is never wrong that's all I know
wait hold your vote for Paul because
he's the only one where did you go from
the mid area the uh like the cafeteria
I don't know the places and then I went
us yeah Ryan yeah
were you rhyme I just went over it
[Music]
oh no I should have killed him oh God
that would have been beautiful
[Music]
where's the body I got the report button
outside the first door to the electrical
I can clear a dream for this one I think
I know dream is so innocent great did
you self-report absolutely not I would
not especially knowing that we just
would need like two more kills to win
well that's true with an emergency so
yeah right just finds all the bodies
magically well it is I'll say this yeah
you know the only one I think this one
has to be corpse
this kill because it's it's why it's why
it's by electrical you said right and
Pewds and toast just came up from the
top I was just like who know the whole
time and I don't think it's Ray based on
that she could have killed me we were
alone like in places
yeah we made eye contacts
give some time so I was with a Pewds in
one of the person that were in the
decontamination right side I was alone
with Ryan time zone in Med Bay Area we
were completely alone there was nobody
there like you know but I'm saying I
would have killed him in like a corner
of the map where no one would be if it
was me I wouldn't kill him in front of
Lights I'm running from Med Bay to the
left right now I and where was dream at
uh
okay yeah reported it absolutely no
right right I I was standing like on the
vent next to Rey like Rey could have
came and killed me if it's between me
and Ray then it is
ah okay
the bad thing is we have no idea who the
other one is streaming cycuno is in
problem isn't he
[Music]
good job good button we had we had
lights so I thought I'm very sorry Ray
but I think we should kill Ray no no no
no no no well it has to be one of your
corpse because everyone else is on the
right side of the
maps dream I believe it's corpse but I
think the safest place
no no see no no it's not the safest Play
Because you know I'm innocent so we
should kill off someone else
run yeah okay listen hear me out right
this is this everyone else was down in
decontamination and the kills on
electrical and the only people that
weren't there were you in corp so either
it's one of you two and the safest play
I think is to vote you off as well what
if there's still two imposters though
that's the problem it has to be one of
you two though we have to split the
pairs
logically there's no two imposter
because if we're wrong about corpse one
would like the other one just gets
one kill how about we just take a more
logical guess because we know I wouldn't
vote out an imposter if I was innocent I
I agree I don't think you like scared
each other at the edge of our vision I'm
pretty sure it's not right I don't think
it's her but either toast or Pewds here
you at least up for
you and said not to vote you out
medicine
okay who is it is
well no I was with dream the whole round
I'm voting rate I I think it's the
safest way I know I trusted
this whole game is about I voted for a
person okay why are you throwing me out
of the money I don't know
it's either toaster I'm not quite sure
but oh that's fine I trust Ray though uh
bro
what the make it end please I don't
call me Billy eilish because I
don't want to be me anymore how is this
possible
killing everyone this time
it's coming out of there
why'd I do that
I guess I wanted vengeance
what was my last time
you're weird I saw him run into space
how long was he dead for I don't know a
while I saw him run into specimen I
thought he was alone he's been done on
violence for a long time I was like I'm
trying to get the out of here
[Laughter]
are they all blue together can't
kill any one of them
uh you want to explain yourself oh uh
corpse let me explain
um
just came out of where the vent was and
there's a body right next right right so
that's how you know it's not us right
um
fair I'm pretty sure it's like and no no
of course let me explain uh Jack Jack
you can tell them right why do you think
it's
just having a party down there
there's a body right next to them and
neither of them call it and they both
come out of where the van is like oh
look at our defense there was nobody
there when we were there
[Music]
to them right next to them like and
they're both saying they didn't see a
body yeah it was it was we were at the
door
yeah I saw it flash by it was like right
below the button like in the hallway and
you didn't I didn't see it at all well I
tried to but corpse got there first but
you know me and Zach are innocent we
were doing the thing the thing Pokey
that makes sense
all right cool double kill
hmm uh just checking to see if someone
died
corpse again which is actually crazy
how the heck did they get it they got it
twice in a row I can't believe it
me and Ray went down through specimen
wear a psychuno and jaguar yeah and lo
and behold they didn't double kill us
and likewise
and yeah I thought the ladies of death
had come to murder the best boys
[Applause]
me and course were the only one fixing
lights nine six lights I think Pewds
should be the person first person we
report because I saw him fake upload I
just didn't want to call it out
you took too long to do it because I did
it at the same time no wait you and Ray
were both there we were literally just
standing there I can tell you what
happened there we all went to it I
oh yeah you lost
[Laughter]
boy
[Applause]
is it the cat ears did that make you
imposter or something yeah
all right take care guys oh yeah all the
best guys the game let's go ahead and
get started see you later I'm glad one
person said goodbye thank you Jack
what a finale I felt like the Among Us
finale right there I like that that was
fun all the best guys remember it's just
a game don't take it too seriously
[Music]